Speaker 1: Let's stick with COVID a little bit
on Fox News. Right after praising COVID vaccines,
Greg GUTFELD very casually segues into COVID
was created by scientists just without even
any hesitation, without any even raising of
an eyebrow. GUTFELD says that. And of course,
we have no evidence for that. That's one of the
early conspiracy theories that surged about COVID.
Take a look at this bizarre clip on Fox News.
Speaker 2: As sick as people were. So I think
that's the that's the thing that we can still have
these conversations. But the president's largely
right and anyone on his team who doesn't believe
it, maybe they should look for other work. Okay,
wrap it up, Greg. Well, I got to go with Harold
on this. I think that if we we cannot have it both
ways. We can't hail Operation Warp Speed and then
laugh about the vaccines. Vaccines may not prevent
COVID, but they certainly reduce the severity
of it. That's what it's there for. But the thing
that drives me crazy is that we still we have
to accept that more than likely it was manmade.
Speaker 1: Why? Why why
would we have to accept that?
Speaker 2: And when you think about
it, it's now the third part of the
cold and flu season. I don't think.
Speaker 1: It's ever going to go away.
I think you can have.
Speaker 2: Cold, flu.
Speaker 1: And COVID.
Speaker 2: It's like our siblings in sickness
got a new little brother like cold and flu.
Speaker 1: Okay. So he's reading that this is,
I guess, comedy. GUTFELD is a comedian, so he's
reading some of this stuff off of his notes, which
is fine, but none of it's funny, and it's also not
true. So this has been studied. Always remember
when a conspiracy theory has attached to it like
a parasite and they won't even let us investigate
Bing. That should set your alarms up. Is
that true? Is that true that we can't even
investigate? The so-called lab leak hypothesis has
been investigated extensively, and there are two
versions of the lab leak hypothesis. One, the most
weaponized is COVID was deliberately created as a
bioweapon and released to kill people. That's one
hypothesis. The slightly less cuckoo hypothesis is
it was being studied and it accidentally escaped
the lab because someone at the lab infected
themselves and then left and then it spread from
there. Those are the two kind of layers. Now,
the view of scientists is that both of those are
very unlikely right now, the most likely scenario.
And again, in science, we talk in terms of
probabilities, the most likely scenario is
what's called the natural zoonotic jump from
animals to humans. The entire idea of lab leak
is based initially on Wuhan markets is where we
were told it came from and there's a virology
lab in Wuhan, so it's very easy to claim it
was from the markets when it was really from
the lab because they're both physically in
proximity. That's the bulk of why people are
talking about this. Now, the truth is, there's
lots of these types of labs in many places,
and that should also kind of make us question
whether that makes sense now. Is it possible
that this was being studied in that particular
lab and someone was accidentally infected and
then they left and then they started spreading
it to other people, and that's how it entered the
human population. It is, of course, possible, but
we have been told no one at that lab was sick at
the time COVID emerged. But could they be lying?
There are claims that that's a lie. Well, you look
at the clusters of early COVID cases and you see
that there are links to multiple markets in Wuhan
around the exact same time. And so that supports
the idea that some animals, animal traders,
brought the virus in animals to the city, brought
those animals to a bunch of the markets in Wuhan,
sold in many markets and spread from there.
Now, you know, we could go further on this
at this point, it's completely irresponsible to
say. We have to admit the most likely scenario
is that this was created by scientists. That
is not the most likely scenario based on what
we know today. If that changes,
I will be the first to tell you